اذا مشاهدينا اوكرانيا تنال اخيرا ما ظلت
تسعى اليه منذ شهور الدبابات الغربيه ستشق
طريقها صوب كاف لدعم القوات في اوكرانيا
في الحرب ضد روسيا طال الانتظار قبل قبول
المانيا وامريكا ارساله دبابات ليوبارد
وابرز لاوكرانيا لكن الانتظار قد يطول
ايضا من اجل الاستفاده منها المهمه لم
تنتهي بعد ويبدو ان الطريق لا يزال طويلا
قبل ان تستطيع القوات الاوكرانيه تصويب
مدافع الدبابات صوب الجيش الروسي فما هي
الصعوبات التي تطفو على السطح الان بعد
الموافقه على ارسال هذه الدبابات الجزء
الصعب يتمثل في نقل المركبات الى ساحه
المعركه فقد كشف مسؤولون امريكيون ان
الامر قد يستغرق سنوات حتى تصل دبابات
ابرامز الى اي مساحات قتال اوكرانيه وذلك
بحسب ما نقلت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز في
تصريح اخر قال جنرال روبرت بي ابرامز وهو
جنرال سابق في الجيش الامريكي سميت
الدبابه على اسم والده قال ان الوقت الذي
سيستغرقه وصول الدبابات لن يكون في 30
يوما بل دون شك سيتطلب مده طويله مع تاخر
سيكون حجره عثر امام الاستفاده استفاده
الاوكرانيين من هذه الدبابات فقبل
استخدامها على ارض المعركه يجب على القوات
الاوكرانيه ان تبدا تدريبا على كيفيه
استخدامها سواء ليوبار الالمانيه او
ابرامز الامريكيه فكلهما معدات تعمل في
تكنولوجيا متطوره وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
شدت ان الولايات المتحده ستدرب القوات
الاوكرانيه على استخدامها هذه الدبابات
قبل تسليمها كما قالت المانيا على لسان
المتحدث باسم الحكومه انها ستبدا تدريب
الاوكرانيين على كيفيه استخدام الدبابات
مشجعه الدول الاوروبيه الاخرى التي لديها
على ان تفعل
شيئا نفسه هناك تحدي اخر فيما يخص
الدبابات وهو امكانيه استهداف روسيا للطرق
او السكك الحديديه او اماكن انطلاق
المعدات اثناء شحنها الى الخطوط الاماميه
في شرق وجنوب اوكرانيا